[Musique]
valérie houle et son conjoint danois
philippe vivent en banlieue de
copenhague depuis onze leurs deux
fillettes lilly et mia prennent un
copieux petit déjeuner avec eux c'est
vraiment important aussi de des cultes
et aux enfants de bien manger et aussi
de les faire participer d'enfer la
nourriture faire le pain parce que les
danois font leur pain
[Musique]
millau fréquentent la garderie la flûte
enchantée où la saine alimentation est
une priorité peut choisir hautement
envoyer ton enfant dans la ville ça va
aller là dessus est ce qui met l'emphase
sur la nourriture biologique est ce que
ils ont la cuisine au même endroit
d'abord il faut que ce soit bio c'est
bon pour l'environnement
et c'est bon pour les enfants d'éviter
les pesticides et les poisons et pour
cuisiner bio il faut tout faire à partir
d'aliments toujours un jour avec la
viande un jour avec du poisson tous les
mercredis les enfants du poisson en 2010
et c'est vraiment si du poisson frais
mkii qui seront cuisinés le jeudi c'est
le jour végétarien dès le vendredi parce
que les enfants ne demandent c'est le
jour 10 meur preuve donc le prince harry
avait quelque chose dessus
pour plusieurs c'est le meilleur repas
de la semaine
il adore le timing ils peuvent composer
eux mêmes leurs tartines équipe comme ça
j'ai demandé aujourd'hui ma fille a eu
des mots durs des crevettes de la part
de filles tous les jours je photographie
les plats qu'on a servi et je les mets
sur internet que les parents les voies
cette garderie n'est pas du tout une
exception en ce qui a trait à
l'alimentation
[Musique]
prenez l'école publique dessus doivent
considérer comme un modèle espace de vie
lumineux aire de jeu spectaculaire et
une véritable cuisine professionnelle
on a quatre jeunes en cuisine tous les
jours elle passe deux semaines par an
avec nous pendant lesquelles ils ne vont
pas en classe les professeurs nous
disent qu'ils sont transformées à leur
retour en classe ils ont plus
d'assurance
on applique les jeunes dans la cuisine
et on ne leur fait cuisiner que du bon
[Musique]
c'est toujours bon et savoureux et c'est
fait avec des vrais aliments
on fait tout en partant de la base c'est
presque tout bio et produits localement
el loco le fou
il faut savoir que la ville de
copenhague s'est dotée en 2007 d'une
politique d'achat pour favoriser la
conversion à l'alimentation biologique
dans toutes les cuisines public
le virage billon nous a servi d'outil
pour eux aussi le professionnalisme en
cuisine la fierté et l'éducation du
personnel mais aussi la satisfaction de
la clientèle
en moins de dix ans la ville a atteint
sa cible les repas offerts sont à 90%
pire un tel exploit n'aurait pas pu
s'accomplir sans même vous ce la maison
de l'alimentation qui chapeaute tout
l'implantation du programme
nous avons deux fils en cuisine nous
avons dont sûrement fort mais au delà de
900 chez qui cuisinent 90 mille repas
par jour dans tous les établissements
publics de copenhague
[Musique]
nous formons les chefs sur
l'amélioration du goût attaquent leur
repas soit savoureux mais le goût est un
outil qui sert à transformer
l'organisation en cuisine il faut
réapprendre la gestion des achats la
planification des menus favoriser les
aliments saisonniers on s'efforce de
réduire le gaspillage de valoriser les
produits frais d'éviter les aliments
transformés et de substituer la viande
par davantage de légumes
le défi c'est le prix
car le bio coûtent plus cher que le
conventionnel ça exige une meilleure
planification ont réussi à faire des
économies en servant la viande et du
poisson qu'une fois par semaine chacun
est végétarien les trois autres jours en
disant de conversion bio nos budgets
n'ont augmenté que de 1,6 pour cent
normalement si on compare avec le
conventionnel un panier bio autres
parfois de bain ou 25% de plus il a
fallu être très rigoureux dans nos
calculs
[Musique]
ce sont des élèves qui met la table les
apprentis cuisiniers servent le repas
avec fierté et les professeurs mange en
compagnie de leur classe les repas coûte
en fait moins de 5 dollars et 90 % des
élèves de l'école sont préval seuls des
écoles les plus récentes ont des
cuisines aussi complet les autres font
affaire avec un fournisseur centrale qui
distribue des repas quotidiens au quart
des élèves dans la cuisine et aux
boulangers six mille petits pains par
jour
nous offrons 4 menu hebdomadaire sur
l'année les gens peuvent les consulter
sur internet faire leur choix pour les
journées des airs et et ils passent leur
commande à l'avant nous sommes
pratiquement à 100% bio et il nous ne
cuisinons qu'à partir du frais nous
faisons tout nous-mêmes
même le ketchup et la sauce tomate
chaque jour dans les bureaux de mère
russe
les employés évalue les repas préparés
par id au même moment où les élèves les
reçoivent à l'école
[Musique]
ce dont je suis plus fier c'est que dans
notre ville nous cuisinons tout de a à z
nous avons fait le virage bio et c'est
tant mieux mais surtout nous servons
maintenant de la vraie nourriture